yo walk him to this video I'm playing
hog and he's playing be three lucky
always does he always plays b3 this guy
I mean it's not a bad move but isn't it
a bit much playing it all the time okay
it's an i am from Spain to 275 a plane
that f6 he will take I have had this
against him numerous times this some
other way to play it's not bad for black
but I'd like to I like some variety so
maybe just develop him he's playing with
them oh he usually plays this for c4
okay I don't don't mind that too much
him looks like healthy development
okay just trade this off gain some space
on the queenside it's not much happening
here in this position she tried to play
a form may be f ing for possible okay
mmm what about Michael Bishop a 3 his
playing
I have a wacky idea b5 if he takes twice
on b5 I have Bishop h2 queen be a check
getting the piece back maybe be five
check check so will this happened I
thought this would be a quite nice for
me but maybe it isn't yeah a fly fsm is
possibly a witness but be three years
also not not a great porn
let's go here first dad yes but i'm not
sure what this Bishop is doing here it's
it's looking like an act of peace but
it's not really I'm doing anything
concrete cannot go Bishop c5
hmm but this means out so cannot really
move the snide
hmm now I need to move the light snow no
way around that it's so bad on d7 and so
this is really ambitious f3 okay so
maybe you just wanted to prevent 94 but
it's weakening it's a weakening move
okay
I still don't really know where to use
this bloody night it's a schizo it's
weird maybe night h5 g3 or something
well I'm not sure that this is all that
grade and if I do need to exchange Queen
sire this is bad we came at least like
this I cannot allow him porn on I'll be
five
yeah this isn't so bad I hope check
check now he wants to get this porn I
need to counter play badly
hi Roxy 7 yeah i mean it's it's very
very bad anyway probably also dead lost
but yeah this was bad allowing the the
trade i know one night is also
completely off side
check this is there some sort of trick
or anything left in this position okay I
need to put them on dark square so that
I have it located for the moment okay
night will go here
nigeria to the only idea left and he's
uh he's just his to cook now he's got a
deadly check yeah and it's a it's a meat
okay let's let's play out to meet him
check check time morning I meet me yeah
what the heck yeah the structure was a
bit uncomfortable and that didn't really
didn't really had an idea here besides
advancing the kingside it was so I
probably need to to play this different
layer early on I Q&A six queen a six
maybe intending 23 or something the
computer gives like a substantial
advantage here which is surprising 'if i
f is good yeah of course if i if i did
not play five Bishop c5 Queenie six yeah
this is the right idea yeah well I was
simply not playing well in this game to
be played this nicely in here doubling
on the c4 and I didn't really have any
big idea can could also just pause but
at the end there's always a five the
night keeps v3 protected so I don't have
any counter play and a5 is just falling
the app not much I needed to play five
here alright thanks for watching